mom made me promise I'd come by today
it's my birthday wait today is your
birthday yeah happy
birthday um it's bread I'm Isabelle yeah
I
[Music]
know most relationships
end friendships
[Music]
romances they break
you
okay if you look closely you'll find
something tragic was
happening are you interested in writing
something for us I don't do assignments
anymore you're a better writer than most
people do anything have you heard the
tapes no of
what Police
Department Hey we've had some Breakin in
my neighborhood and there's a real
suspicious guy looks like he's up to no
good or
something I want to be in the
story really inside the
story and build a thesis that shows how
all of this is
linked I got to be honest with you I
don't understand I don't see
it you go and write your stories folks
need to know about
this you're trying to make sense of
racism but your thesis is
flawed it was all lies they knew we
weren't
inferior you don't escape trauma By
ignoring
it you escape trauma by
[Music]
confronting I don't write
questions I write
[Music]
answers